hi guys welcome today's episode of off
the rails
in our previous episode we talked about
how there's people who
do what's called shifting when they can
will themselves
into the world of harry potter for real
not imagination
they're really there in hogwarts so
today i'm going to be using the
ravenclaw method
to shift myself into the world of harry
potter i have the crew here who's going
to be
giving me positive affirmations that i
am indeed a wizard which i know i
am and eventually hopefully this is
gonna end up with me
having a um sexual encounter with hagrid
that's the goal here folks so with that
being said let's get on shifting boys
and girls watching you boys but girl
everybody watching the raven method
involves laying in a starfish position
and counting to 100
usually with subliminals playing or with
positive affirmations said between
numbers
all right let's do let's start the
ceremony guys all right here we go i'm
just going to relax
so what we're just you're a wizard and
[ __ ] like
what are we i don't know how are we
affirming you you're a wizard you can
use magic
is real all right ethan you're wizard
you're wizard you're a wizard
or anything you're a wizard
too mighty
[Music]
can you guys maybe just try like i'm
trying to do harry potter why are you
talking about david copperfield he's a
magician
can you try a little bit harder he's an
illusionist he doesn't have a [ __ ] he
can't do an abracadabra you can't do a
patronus
can you guys try a little harder please
because you're killing me okay gandalf's
pretty good
gandalf is [ __ ] lord of the rings bro
he was a good character one you're a
wizard
you're a wizard you're always amazing
86 89
[Music]
oh my god oh
i can't believe it i'm in harry potter
is that dobby come over here doggy
oh my goodness it's so nice to see you
hello you don't talk hi oh that sounds a
lot like love but wow it looks
just like dobby i can't believe oh my
god
is that the hogwarts express
david come right on the hogwarts with me
the hogwarts express
yes this is i've shifted
let's go dobby let's go to hogwarts on
the hogwarts express baby
he's gonna [ __ ] kill himself jesus
christ ethan
ethan do you see that
tommy stop budgeting and listen look
that's voldemort you had a chance
to kill hitler as a baby would you take
it
i would
[Music]
[Music]
we did it we did it bobby
[Music]
we did it tommy we did it dobby
we saved hogwarts [ __ ] you [ __ ]
get him the [ __ ] off that catchment
[Music]
i saved hogwarts just let me smell your
armpit
what the [ __ ] where am i what is all
this
lovebot what happened to you
lovebot how did this happen to you
oh damn dan you can fix him right he's
happy to be with his friends
it's his time no no no don't say that
love bot
such a beautiful place no dad can you
fix him
no
[Music]
he's dead he's dead
hey it's off the rails we're back
totally off the rails as usual today's
episode is sponsored by bespoke
post and upstart love are you okay
he's fine you know he's fine he's
indestructible i'm doing fine
i'll tell you what that lovebot is
pretty hardy though it's no gatsby but
it's take already taken a good amount of
punishment
yeah it seems to be in good working
order oh yeah
so what um i shifted you guys i
was able to achieve shifting
and you know it was everything they said
it would be immoral
i killed voldemort
i had a sexual experience with hagrid
where his [ __ ] filled like the whole
cabin yeah we left that part out of the
edit but
uh yeah it was too graphic it got pretty
30 seconds it got pretty weird in here
i filled the whole cabin the roof
fell off was blasted off splinters
everywhere but i was enveloped
in his [ __ ] mean like a blanket of [ __ ]
meat of hagrids
yeah people thought when i was
describing uh hogwarts
uh uh hagrid's growing penis people
thought that i was really into
fan fiction is fan fiction really like
that
don't play dumb are you stopping
do they really talk like that like his
[ __ ] meat grew and blew off the cabin
and i was
enveloped in it anal sex i'm not super
i'm not uh super deep into the world of
fan fiction myself
either but um i thought i was being over
the top but here's the comments if you
guys don't believe me
ethan's hagrid shifting fanfic was way
too detailed i know he's done it before
not gonna lie the draco fanfic and
ethan's voice was probably the most
unsettling thing on the planet yeah well
basically the actor who plays dracco tom
felton
is a fan of teddy fresh vis-a-vis
anything's possible draco although yeah
it's
whatever and my fantasy is draco
ethan putting his english college degree
to good use with that harry potter fan
fiction thank you that's a compliment
this second kid is going to go back and
watch this expecting something wholesome
just to be ass blasted by harry potter
fanfics
[Music]
what is that referring to to your second
child on the way because
the episode that the pregnancy was
announced so it's kind of
posterity they might go back and watch
it and they're just going to see their
dad
ranting about hagrid's stick for 20
minutes that makes sense
yeah i wonder what the kids are gonna
think about this i mean they're gonna
it's just interesting to think that
they're gonna have all this content to
tap into
right yeah yeah i mean
something tells me they won't care or be
interested because usually
kids don't they're not impressed maybe
not as kids or teenagers but um
but maybe later in life you know you
think so you think they'll respect me
what i've done with my career
you know hagrid we'll find out don't you
want to wouldn't be wouldn't you want to
lay in bed in a [ __ ] blanket
hagrid's giant wizard [ __ ] uh we
actually have a caller
um on discord who reached out to me who
had some uh
first-hand experience with uh shifting
and you're not gonna leave we have a
shift there yeah and not
it's not just any shifter you're you're
gonna be put them on i'm really
impressed i have so many questions all
right ladies and gentlemen
the president of the united states
joseph robinette biden
robinette what's his middle name robin
robinette joseph joe
fox man look hey here i am man look
you bet your bottom dollar i know about
about shifting man
wow so tell me about your experience
with shifting uh the president of the
united states is a shifter
that's awesome look i'm a huge potter
head i
shifted once and it had their hogwarts
and i got the opportunity i got her
hermione or her mini granger i smelled
her hair
and one of the best memories wow you
want to confess that right now that you
shifted just to smell hermione's hair
that's a little bizarre
her hair is luscious luscious locks man
look
and i remember past passing the crime
bill back in 94 that was another
another one of my favorite memories man
okay the crime well okay cool uh in
harry potter or in real life because i'm
confused now what you're talking about
folks this is this uh this is real
there's a real world
real world with the wizards oh oh oh
okay
does joe know where he i'm uh joe maybe
he's shifting right now
joe are you okay yeah okay so you want
to tell me about your shifting
experience
kind of like how did you how did you get
involved in shifting what did you do
when you were shifting
yeah yeah sure sure thing fatso fats
what
ethan that's rude i know i know
one two three or four about shifting man
look
when i shift my my 52 plymouth crayon
book
up to to 65 all the birds do a soda
found soiree down by
don levy's cattle crow's nest that's all
right thank you joe
i don't he's i don't think he knows you
ever shifted the black
magic senate to champ joyce randolph
sean all right you can cut you you can
cut them off okay i'm sorry joe and joe
thank you thank you for your
contribution joe biden um
well we did get that he smelled hermione
granny's hair but everything else was
intelligible wow joe biden yeah
you think joe biden would have something
better to do than call our show
yeah pandemic there's like you know
right there's like so many problems in
this country
watching harry potter shifting tick tock
not sure
you're living yo you guys gotta see this
so you all remember the no such thing as
a coincidence
that great meme from tick tock in fact
let me show it to renew your guys's
memory
um let me find it there's no such thing
as a coincidence
here it is there's all right so cut in
[Music]
let us know when you're getting in go
ahead okay
all right you guys remember this guy he
goes there's no such thing as a
coincidence we're energetically aligned
and he just talks about some random
[ __ ]
here no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that you're watching this video
means you are energetically aligned with
me
and aquafarians aquafarians
mermaids so he he uses the fact that i'm
watching the video being such a
coincidence that whatever he says is
true
it was great it's a great meme okay
we've learned recently that there may
not be
such thing as a coincidence he was right
he was right there's no such thing as a
coincidence
yo okay this is such a deep rabbit hole
trisha paytas with the no such thing as
a coincidence guy
in a video from 2016. now this gets even
crazier okay
no such thing as a coincidence with
trisha paytas and then guess who's this
girl
that's the other that's the girl we were
talking about like an episode or two ago
she was the 16 year old courtney stodden
yeah who
was married to like a 50 year old or
whatever she was married to the 50 year
old
from the green mile the shitty guard how
is this possible that everything comes
connected
dude we are energetically aligned this
is insane
the fact that tricia did a video with
him and courtney and stoddard in 2016
means there's no such thing as a
coincidence there's no such thing as a
coincidence
wow there's no such thing as a
coincidence
i wonder if he should harry potter
shifts
does that blow your guys's mind i mean
this is insane yeah when i saw that
somebody posted it on the subreddit and
i was
i was flabbergasted i thought it was
just they were just goofing at first and
was like oh
this guy just looks like him but if you
look at the instagram account it's the
same guy william
knight i believe well and then the weird
thing too is like we go oh is there no
such thing as a coincidence guy that's
crazy but then we watch the video we go
oh my god that's also important
or whatever her name is who we just
talked about just talked about are you
sure this is the same guy he looks so
different
it's the same guy holy [ __ ] bro we are
so
energetically aligned
there is no such thing as a coincidence
whoa
i literally we are so energetically
aligned
did this happen
bro the fact that you've watched this
video of me reacting that right now
means that the government is going to
put out a classified
they're supposed to build the classified
thing this month of ufos and all the
ufos are going to be trisha paytas all
the aliens are trisha paytas no such
thing as a coincidence
there's no such thing as a coincidence
how is it that trisha paytas
is in literally everything she's been
everywhere
there's no such thing as a coincidence
there is no such thing as a coincidence
trisha paytas was pictured
this is gonna blow your mind if i can
find my cursor this is going to blow
your mind
trisha paytas was pictured
at the assassination of jfk there's no
such thing as the queen
on the grassy knoll this is her right
here explain that
we are energetically aligned right
you're the second shooter she may have
been i mean how
i mean what the [ __ ]
[Music]
trisha paytas was at the o.j simpson
trial
did you know that there's no such thing
as the coin there is no such thing as a
coincidence we are energetically aligned
she looks like she's having a good time
she's there yeah she's having way too
much fun this is a serious situation
there's no such thing as a coincidence
gotta note that the music's too loud
trisha paytas was in india with the
beatles apparently wow
didn't expect that one there's no such
thing as the coincidence
yeah she fits right in bro trisha paytas
has been everywhere
she's been on every show and in every
reality
trisha paytas was at the muhammad ali
with this picture whatever this was
round one jesus you too there's no such
thing as president
wow she's energetically aligned with
everything what if trisha is literally
like the comment thread in the whole
universe like she
is string theory she ties all the
universes together
yeah she's like the god particle
trisha peters was at tenement square
massacre
and she's posing she's like cheers she's
like
there's no such jeez as a coincidence
this is insane i cannot believe what i'm
seeing
trisha paytas at the titanic taking a
cannonball
that's just inappropriate there's no
such thing as the coin this is just not
taking the situation seriously yeah
there's a tragic event there's no such
thing as a coincidence though
trisha paytas uh uh
uh what the [ __ ] is this that's uh
vladimir
lenin with uh in the russian revolution
she was at the russian revolution she's
a communist comrade
vladimir putin there's no i cannot
believe this
that's why this was with abraham lincoln
um during the civil war ladies and
gentlemen wow
even though she doesn't seem to know
what the civil war is she was there
yeah she didn't she didn't learn she
didn't stop to learn that much
oh my god she filmed an apology video on
the moon
that is outrageous
i cannot believe this information i have
a lot of ques she was at the last
supper holy [ __ ] wait she's jude isn't
that judas
that's where judas sat i i don't know
holy [ __ ]
a little late on that sound drop i
cannot believe what i've learned about
trish payton
yeah there's no such thing as a
coincidence there's no such thing as the
coins that tripped me out
so we had to do a whole thing about it
i gotta ask her about this it seems like
she's in a sexual relationship with them
in front of me totally honest
or that girl especially
they're just they're just being girls
really
i don't know in a night out i don't know
i don't i don't make out with my homies
like that maybe i should start
i know it looks like she's trying to
[ __ ] if i'm just interpreting what i'm
looking at
gotta ask her about this man i'm gonna
come
anyway
so there's some ahead so we've got quite
a show here coming up we've got andrew
callahan formerly from all gas no breaks
calling in in a little bit
to discuss his his new channel basically
is a really interesting story behind
his departure from all gas snow breaks a
show that we love
and uh his establishing of channel five
so looking forward to that and until
then
did you get i'm having a hard time
this is a big drama on youtube
minecraft drama dream
is this minecraft youtube speedrunner
who's like
catapulted to fame i mean if you go to
his channel here
um gosh he he has 22 million but i feel
like he just got started like a year ago
23 million subs
just watching my algorithms get crushed
right
and his he's got these these minecraft
videos that have like 30
to 90 million views now i'm not putting
a value judgment i don't know anything
about minecraft so i'm not saying like
oh this content stupid river i don't
you know i don't know clearly it's good
people love it you know
do any of you guys know anything about
dream uh
i i was aware of him just because his
presence on the internet is kind of hard
to avoid uh
i think he's been big i think he's been
growing for a while
you know it wasn't just recently
although i agree
i feel like i just heard about him yeah
in the last year it seems like he's
really just everywhere well hold on his
oldest v i don't know if he erased but
his oldest videos from one year ago
he must have erased i'm looking at his
social blade for that channel right now
and it was created in 2014
um so uh the the at least the channel's
been around for a lot longer than that
this time last year he had just over 2
million subs
wow wow so in one year's time he's
gained 21 million subbies
right so the guy he's apparently this
minecraft savant who's been like
breaking records and doing all this
crazy [ __ ]
but like what's interesting to me is
that
he's been accused of cheating quite a
bit
and he's gotten into f there's like it
reminds me of the king of kong you know
this documentary where
mm-hmm pretty similar it's it's
like all these people get into it about
uh donkey kong
who has the top record someone's accused
of cheating it's all this is so dramatic
but it's so entertaining
so love has been in a dispute
with the minecraft mods you just you
just said
love has been in a dream
i didn't realize you were involved yeah
i haven't cheated in minecraft as far as
i know
that's exactly that's that's literally
what dream is that that's what with this
screen what is with love screen
what's with yeah
my eyes there you go okay
so um he's been accused of cheating by
like the mods okay of the speed run
website and he and then he
even he went so as far to prove that
he's not cheating is that he hired some
harvard mathematician to write
proofs about how he's not stealing
and and it's boiled up to the point
where
dude here let let me it's it's i cannot
believe the drama
of all this let me show you guys first
of all
some of dreams world records because i
don't even know what the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
is
well it's not a world it's not a world
record but
what does it mean to speed run minecraft
well minecraft
has a has a an end
right i guess of it and stuff i mean
most people play it in a very kind of
just like
open way where you just kind of do
whatever you want but um
but there is there is an actual game to
it well when i was playing there was no
game
but i guess now they added [ __ ] where
like there's a you have to get to the
ender dragon and kill the ender dragon
right yeah and that's so that's it's a
speed run to do that okay i see
so um
well yeah here it is let's watch the big
moment
he's gonna take out that winter dragon
boys
crafting uh
picking
yes let's get it
exciting stuff
we got a stone axe on deck
let's go i guess this video is really
long here i want one yeah we had a time
stamp to
the end i'm not sure uh what happened to
that it's just kind of chaotic i feel
bad for feelings
go yeah there you go that was the end
right there
oh he just dynamited him or something
yeah using some like exploit you know
like most speed runs
let's go okay
you gotta hear what he says right here
though oh really yeah
knowing what we know now hell yeah
hell yeah
oh my god i'm so
happy but i am so mad
dude that would have been world record
that could have been world record i had
insane luck
oh my god yeah insane in that room at
like 12 minutes dude
if i took the same time on the end that
that just took just then that okay so he
says insane luck
so these mods have been crunching the
numbers being like
the the amount of luck you get is
impossible
in short like in a in a random number
generated world it's it's
it's uh impossible here's a video of
them calling him out
here let's see let's take a look at
dreams odds
this isn't exactly a good look across
six streams dream bartered 262 times and
got 42 pearl traits
which when plugged into the formula
comes in at 1 in 177 billion
so these guys crunch the numbers they're
like this is just visually it's just
mathematically impossible
and then dream instead of being like yo
you guys got me or whatever
he goes out of his way he like wages war
on these mods
that are like these small community mods
he accuses them of like
lying and trying to to like defame him
and [ __ ] i mean
they're cloud chasers just like yeah
it's like anybody who says anything
about anybody on the internet yeah let's
see here's after tweet about it
my 1.16 run was just rejected after
research due to it being too unlikely to
verify
a video was made by a head mod and
youtuber geo square using my name and
click baitings cheating bro look he's so
difficult
to get easy views he's literally calling
him a clown chaser
let's go the problem is
with this talking about this dream guy
is that he has like very
scary dedicated fans bro this is like
some
this is like giving me flashbacks to bts
this you don't want to ever cross dream
fans bruh i mean yeah the dream fans are
the dream fans are uh pretty intense but
nothing compared to the army still oh
really okay that's good yeah
army strong love bts by the way heart we
love bts bro never die
never surrender bts bts forever
oh my god but anyway this guy youtuber
geosquare who now he's [ __ ] on he's
a small time youtuber as he said
using my name to get easy views
definitely responds to total bs
currently have multiple mods messaging
me that they believe the verdict was
biased
and they might quit the mod team what
kind of investigation was this
well anyway of course these guys were
right
as he showed it was like a one in 77
billion chance that he would get so
lucky on his speed runs to get like the
[ __ ] he gets
and um this guy was so dedicated to
proving his innocence
he had a minecraft statistician or a
harvard statistician write an extract
look at this [ __ ] bro are you [ __ ]
kidding me how is this not king of kong
[ __ ]
this is a 17 page i think even longer i
think it's like 19 pages
something like that king kong ain't got
[ __ ]
what is this report this word is a
discussion on minecraft speedo or dream
who during a live stream with speed
running
attempts on the minecraft 1.16 random
seed glitches
experience fairly low probability events
over seemingly specific lengths of time
extremely rare events pique our interest
and we can reque and we can require an
explanation eg the purpose of deciding
whether dream speed runs are eligible
for official leaderboards
so we hired this guy commissioned him
wrote this whole scientific
[ __ ] is this bro this has got to be a
documentary this is some king of kong
[ __ ] for sure
look at this section 6.1 binomial
distribution for blaze rod drops
6.2 probability evaluations for elder
elder pearls ender pearls
i can now calculate the probability of
receiving the number of successful
trades of dream six streams in question
i was like whoa bro this is insane
blaze rod probability we got curves
hell yeah we got ender pearl boost
amount versus interpol uh
plot by photo execute i don't know bro
i mean look at this have you i've never
seen video games taken to this level
before
let's go so
at any rate god i mean wow this this is
insane
we got maths and everything man
so here you go okay now it comes out
that apparently people started calling
and the question this scientist who he
hired
this is an astrophysicist that graduated
from harvard to prove that he didn't
cheat in a 19 page report detailing why
he didn't cheat
and why the accusations of geo square
was wrong
here's dream talking about why you hired
this astrophysicist
this is amazing stuff you guys come on
even if you're not into minecraft which
i'm not at all
yeah me neither but this story is just
so good professor with a phd that
graduated from harvard that's actually a
practicing astrophysicist
that is an expert in statistics and
astro statistics
after reaching out to this expert he
insisted that if he was going to do this
analysis
that i must agree to release his
findings regardless of if they made me
look good or they made me look bad
knowing that i'm innocent i agreed the
mod team is a group of respectable
people but they're also young and a
group of volunteers so it's hard to
fault them for making mistakes when
compared to a full-time professional
with a specific expertise in a field
like this
after extensive research into the mods
math and the logic and reasoning behind
this math
the expert found that the math was off
okay so yeah i mean yeah so
now people are going over this
astrophysicist math
and being like yo you made a bunch of
errors and then when this guy
started getting heat from people
apparently he just disappeared right
he dipped he just was like uh bro what
did you get me into
which is kind of what i'm wondering what
i'm getting myself into oh yeah
leave dream alone
so these are the small time mods who
he's [ __ ] on and calling liars by
the way
minecraft speedrun this you know they've
got
let's see 4 500 followers on twitter you
know
that he's beefing with this guy with 23
million subs right
following the report released by photo
execute
excitation that was commissioned by
dream numerous qualified sources have
examined the math
and found considerable flaws both in the
method methodology and accuracy of
calculations
our team has compiled a short response
addressing the claims
and the critique this response attempts
to clarify our original statement as
well as critique the math
in the report we continue to stand by
the conclusion that there is no feasible
legitimate way dream experienced his
rates in the october
uh 16 speed run attempt amazing
uh amazing
look at the top comments by the way top
comment is
dream did not cheat not because of his
position but statistically possible
speaking there is always a chance
there's always a chance
there's no such thing as a coincidence
yeah i mean i know that what's the
chance that trisha was in a photo with
both those people
there's always a chance there's no such
thing as the coin i love this like
this like 15 year old is trying to do
like uh
he's trying to argue with like
mathematicians bro there's always a
chance
if we use the lottery for example the
chances are are absolutely slim but
there are so many different
probabilities but it isn't impossible
here's another one jesus you got to
leave him alone let him have his [ __ ]
speed run
no feasible ways basically saying
impossible
yeah so there you have it
now i don't know what exactly prompted
dream
to put this out but now he recently just
fessed up to it he made a statement
being like yeah i [ __ ] cheated
what prompted him to do that do you know
that's a good question i guess maybe
just mounting pressure
from people pointing out that all of his
arguments don't make any sense i mean
in retrospect you know now that we
know that he did cheat and that these
mods were right i mean it was
of course he cheated like they said it
was like a 1 in 17 billion chance that
this happened it's like i'll tell you
it's so obvious to be able to understand
the games
if things are appearing like way too you
know there's a really interesting story
i used to play a lot of poker in college
and there was people playing
poker who had super admin access
and these guys who play poker on a high
level are like brilliant mathematicians
and they started noticing like this guy
is winning
way too often and something doesn't add
up
so they started crunching this random
person's numbers they would play
they would sit at the table with him and
and then analyze his hands over like 10
000 hands
and they could show very clearly on a
chart that the
the the amount of hands he was winning
and the plays he was doing compared to
other pros
was like way off the charts like
economical and that's how they caught
this guy it was like this huge scandal
back in the 2000s
that somebody from like the pokerstars
team was [ __ ] playing high level
poker with the super admin account
and these mathematicians this is what
they did with dreams run it just
dream is this guy
right the king of kong guy yeah you got
to watch the king of com that bro i
this needs to be a documentary well
dream is anonymous he doesn't show his
face so i don't know you wouldn't be
able to involve him i guess
this was the villain from king of kong
he had all the records
and it turns out he got like all of his
scores scrubbed for cheating so
you know
i cannot find my [ __ ] cursor okay
so for some reason he put out this
statement and then immediately deleted
it like this guy is just kind of
bro i don't understand this dude
basically he says it's a really long
post and kind of i when i first read
this i thought it was like a
ironic i was like does this [ __ ]
serious
like i feel this is something important
to talk about i've been very withheld
for a while about it and just decided
i'd probably be best just let it out so
i can feel relaxed a little more
this will be a very long read yada yada
oh he goes
i'm writing this in my bathtub at 4 am
on my phone so forgive my mistakes
he wrote this on his phone come on
you expect me to believe you wrote this
on your phone in his bathtub like
candlelit
you cheated on your speedrun i don't
believe anything he says now
back in november 2020
i for the first time since 1.16 had
released
i decided to try a speed run and get a
decent time
my goal was to get faster than 25
minutes
which was a pretty good time and fairly
obtainable
yada yada well his is exp it's so
[ __ ] long you guys
yeah we definitely don't need to read
the whole thing but what he what he ends
up fessing up to is that he does have a
mod installed and
uh yeah that changed the drop rates just
like everybody had said from the
beginning
and he said oh i didn't know he's like i
just he said i just
changed the drop rates because it would
save me time from having to start new
games every time
well specifically to
to give his argument a fair shake what
he's saying is that he
didn't think the mod that he had
installed affected
the speed run so he knew it was
installed but he had it installed for
his other content because he doesn't
just do speedrunning he's just like a
general i'm sorry but if you understand
the game as good as he does you
understand absolutely i think he's full
of [ __ ] but this is just
this is what he's saying is that like
it's so if he has this mod installed to
make these rare items drop way more
common
it's so obvious when you're playing and
it's working or not yeah come on dude
yeah so obvious well he's just getting
lucky that's what he said in the
at the end i got so lucky
you know it's funny and then he gets an
argument with all these people where
they're like there's no possible way to
get that lucky and he's like i don't
know there's
there's a chain talking about there's
always a chance
hell yeah you know i had a physics
teacher in college he goes
you know there's a chance that you could
just fall through the earth because the
molecules just align
it's like a one and a quadruple billion
chance but there's a chance
so anything's possible
right
i wish i had some choice passages from
this was there anything funny worth
talking about in this
the the fact that he was writing in the
bathtub is probably the funniest part
at 4am yeah dick in hand
yep hey guys i just beat off a quick one
and i'm feeling really relaxed
soaking in my own filth i'm typing this
on my cell phone so please
ooh baby no no no no there is kind of a
fanfic about dream even though it
doesn't show his face he's got like that
corpse husband thing where they go
i'm soaking in a bathtub i just wipe
i just cleaned my ass i don't ever i'm
in the bathtub sitting in
poop and stitches my candlelight
oh yeah
so anyway i just thought i thought the
whole story arc was super interesting
how
he like hired this mathematician
relentlessly attacked these poor mods
who were right in the end
right it's worth noting too that and i
won't necessarily put this on him
but he we were alluding to his rabid fan
base this was part of it
those mods were getting like just
horrible death threats and [ __ ]
sent to them by you know his supporters
and everything because
they were right those poor guys so you
would think that his
fans would be pissed like oh my god we
defended you and
you cheated this whole time after all
this back and forth and drama
here's the here's the if i'm being
honest i don't care you cheated i like
watching your content for fun and many
other people do i like you said you were
never a professional speedrunner you
only did it for fun
bro you hired a mathematician what's fun
about that
you literally went and bought hard and
made this whole hub about how you got a
harvard educated phd to write a
dissertation i need that clout
that guy could have been working on
something important and he's writing
papers about speed runs that were faked
you know what i mean we don't have very
much phd physic physicians
physicians physic physicians
[Music]
physics decisions in the
[Music]
people go this is what i've been trying
to explain you're getting so much hate
over a block game
bro you're the one that hired the
physicist
he's like i need albert he's like put
together his own like uh
manhattan project to prove he wasn't
cheating i need all the biggest brains
in the world
to prove that these mods of a 4 500
follower twitter account are lying about
me
[Music]
i can't believe people are so upset over
minecraft well i'm with him there
no you're living but basically they're
like oh it's just a misunderstanding
we love you i don't care about dream
though
this thing was weird billy mitchell
vibes
[Music]
yeah so he erased his apology that he
he wrote at 4 00 a.m in a pool of in a
bathtub of his own jizz
yeah and then he goes this guy lie i
don't know this guy must be a
pathological
liar or something because there's
nothing he says makes sense like guys
use your brain he goes
pastebin i post the other day was
removed by staff no it wasn't
yeah it's not a thing i just come on
dude you don't have to lie to kick it
bro
you know what i'm saying so i deleted
the tweet so annoying okay bro
sure so annoying the paste bin mods
deleted your post
no they didn't so repost it
this guy lies about everything i'm
telling you
i can tell and then he talked about in a
video
here he is
when i when i saw this video this is
where i fully turned on him
oh really well just hear what he said
okay so this is him addressing the whole
controversy after the fact
um hbo please pick this up
it'd be a whole different story if i was
like you know i don't know maybe
it'd be i feel like it's one of those
situations where communication was the
biggest
flaw i guess communication
miscommunication bad communicate poor
communication between me and the mod
team
poor communication between me and the
dev and then
just emotions i guess um you know i had
i had you know i had huge emotions the
monty met huge emotions
um the public had huge emotions you know
my fans had huge emotions it was just
like this [ __ ] fest of everybody being
hugely emotional and uh what is hugely
emotional
i've never heard that i've expressed it
that way before i've never heard
uh the problem was i was lying
expressed as i missed communicating yeah
well yeah that's one way to put it yeah
i guess miss
a lie is a miscommunication in a way so
he's like bro oh oh
i was cheating the whole time i forgot
totally misunderstood i i i i
miscommunicate when i said
when i said that you're full of [ __ ] i
didn't cheat i
i misspoke i missed you he's like they
miscommunicated too it was a whole
communication breakdown
you know everybody's kind of at fault
here right
minecraft a lot of blame to go around on
this in this whole situation
i just find it so ironic that his fans
are now like why is everyone getting
heated over minecraft but that's his
whole life he's the guy who's like
a minecraft guy yeah oh yeah you want
him to take it seriously or not
right and play that again zach yeah
that's him oh yeah
hell yeah what are we talking about he
sounds pretty hyped he sounds
like he's pretty into it right
basically i don't i feel like it's one
of those things where it's just
it's a it's a shitty situation
regardless stream the elmo game right
now
nah uh i don't know i'll wait i'll see
i'll see what donkey says let's see what
dunkey says oh donkey made a video about
him slamming him [ __ ] slammed him
donkey i can't i can never tell if
donkey's actually being serious or not
but his video was so funny
you know i i was watching the whole
thing waiting for the bait and switch
because oftentimes he'll kind of troll
with that kind of stuff and then the
video just ends with dreams of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah he sucks and yeah but he actually
just [ __ ] on dream
okay that's awesome it was short too i
kind of want to watch it
yeah no i mean i think people at this
point uh people made up their mind
either way like people are acting like
this like
this like mental thing and
you confess well i guess he means do you
buy my excuse that i didn't know i was
shooting or right
right right me a professional minecraft
player that's dedicated my old life to
minecraft
didn't know i'm unaware that's like an
mlb
like a baseball player being like i
swear to god i didn't know the bat was
corked
i was just using a bat it felt the same
it's like bro
the bat feels very different when it's
corked and you're a professional player
you know that shut the [ __ ] up
you just lied about paste bin removing
your post that didn't happen
right and the whole thing was that this
he he got lucky
over the course of six videos so it's
like
yeah you have one time where it's like
holy [ __ ] i'm just getting
god rolls right now everything's going
my way sure
but when you do it six times in a row
and your entire life is minecraft you
know something's off
after after even two times in a row
sometimes
you get what you [ __ ] deserve oh [ __ ]
yeah i just want to watch this
documentary so bad it would be so good
especially if we get dunky to narrate
running a misinformation campaign in
order to try and
like be like oh dream dream you need to
get taken down like
he cheated in his manhunt he cheated in
his speed runs he cheated and all that
cheating and everything like even if you
even if you say
um even if you want to believe that i
intentionally cheated on
the one 1.16 submitted run on twitch
um which i didn't but if you want to
believe that i did that's fine
okay but don't try and discredit my
accomplishments or
my youtube channel for something that
wasn't on my youtube channel
was never uploaded on my youtube channel
never had anything
youtube channel i've never posted i'm
like this guy's a cheater bro what's
that
cheats i don't know anything about them
please don't hang please don't kill me
dream fans just listen to what i'm
saying
the pace spins the story you know that's
[ __ ]
i'm sorry the mods don't care
explain to me one rationale where this
pace spin
mods delete his post for no [ __ ]
reason
doesn't happen oh my gosh yes here you
want to watch donkey's video about this
and i have to say i don't know anything
about minecraft i really need to
i'm just captivated by the story yeah i
mean i i
i'm not a minecraft player myself and
but it's just
it's shakespearean bro yeah exactly it's
like this fall from grace you can't help
but uh
be taken in by it so this video is
called
taking back my apology to dream i don't
know
i guess did they have some kind of beef
yeah he had made
he explains in this video that he had
previously
made a video calling him a cheater and
then he
made another video apologizing to dream
and now this video is his retraction of
his apology
i love donkey yeah legend [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] does clip mean
is this a new feature yeah oh is this on
every video
uh i think so yeah huh dream cheese i
think it's something for gaming
oh for real oh yeah it's there competing
with the twitch
clips thing
okay here we go
well i can't believe i'm actually saying
this but
can you turn it up
dream cheated you guys this is such a
horrific day for the minecraft community
for people that are out of the loop on
the dream drama
five months ago the famous speedrunner
dream got caught cheating in a speed run
so i made a video called minecraft speed
on her dream busted for
cheating drama but then dream put out a
video proving
and notice how proving is in quotation
marks there he put out a video proving
he didn't cheat
so then the whole internet flipped to
being back on dream side
so i had to make an apology video to
dream otherwise my channel could have
been cancelled
well turns out that apology video was a
huge waste of my time because
dream really did cheat yep just
yesterday
dream admitted on twitter that he
cheated in his speed run
hey guys dream here i'm writing this
10-page
document in my math at 4am on my phone
blah blah blah bunch of dumb [ __ ] turns
into pictures i didn't have cheat codes
on
whoops lazy son of a [ __ ] now you guys
know how big of a dream fan i
am so to see this five months after
defending this guy
tirelessly from all the trolls and all
the non-believers
and then turns out he actually was
cheating this whole time i
i just i you know what
i'm not a dream fan anymore yeah i said
it i'm not a dream fan anymore i am so
sick of this guy lying to his fans
distorting the truth
sending all of his fans on witch hunt
against me and then to top it all off he
actually cheated this entire time
and you know what game we cheated at
minecraft yeah
let that sink in dream cheated at
minecraft a game designed for five year
olds
seriously all you do in this game is hit
dirt with a pickaxe and eat chicken and
dream here to cheat at that
children can beat this game but dream
the supposed master of minecraft he had
to cheat at a game that children can
beat
it is absolutely pathetic dream how
about this
speedrun an actual video game that
people speed run
like mario 64. oh wait you actually have
to be good at video games to speed run
mario 64.
never mind also there's no cheats for
mario 64 so i guess you could never ever
speed run that one here's a game for you
to speed run dream elmo's letter
adventure
your fans would love this game oh wait
you actually have to know the entire
alphabet to speedrun this game
dream you could speedrun pokemon but
you'll probably die instead
so there it is everybody the mods were
right dream cheated and i'm gonna be
honest here my apology video
i was actually being sarcastic that
entire time
yep i knew he cheated all along dream
you blew it
you embarrassed yourself and you ruined
minecraft for everyone i can no longer
play minecraft because of you because
you are such a horrible person
every time i see the enderman all i can
think about is when dream's career ended
because he cheated
so there it is everybody dream sucks we
all hate dream now
he is a [ __ ] he is terrible at video
games and i am really hoping that i
don't have to do
another apology video after this because
i would look really stupid now if i had
to do another one
yeah there was no twist it's usually
irony
he sucks he's a [ __ ] we don't like
dream folks
all right we uh we gotta go to break oh
[ __ ] okay
all right let's go to break thank you
bespoke post for sponsoring us after
spending last summer on the sidelines
we're all ready to get back out there
make this year's lounge season an epic
one
so bespoke post is here to make your
sand
sun and surf game to the next level with
a new lineup of must-have
boxes of awesome collections for you
guys now we actually picked out a box of
awesome
it was a caprese salad kit
yeah and they send it in a way where
it's like you
you get the basil and then they send you
[ __ ] to like make your own mozzarella
cheese bread as a basil plant
it's yeah it's like the whole thing they
send you the plant they go they send you
the cheesecloth
so all of a sudden you're out here like
a [ __ ] mad scientist making your own
a bomb ass crazy we did that in the
office yeah it's pretty sweet
i i got some pubes in it on accident so
nobody wanted to do that didn't happen
i was the only one that ate it but it
tasted really good didn't happen
no it was amazing but they they've got a
ton of like
awesome collections for you guys to
choose from you choose your favorite one
you just have a great time
bespoke post only sends you guys the
best stuff every month no matter what
you're into
they've got a box of awesome that has
you covered from breezy
summer styles and grooming goods to
travel and outdoor gear
box of awesome has collections for every
part
of your life get started take the quiz
at box of awesome dot
com and your answer will help them pick
the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time each box costs
only 45 bucks but it's got 70 dollars
worth of gear inside so if you guys want
to sign up and spice up your summer
and have a fun time with that box of
awesome
you get 20 percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com
use code h3 for 20 off your first box
thank you when it comes to paying off
debt it can keep
feeling like an uphill battle you've got
high interest rates resulting in a
minimum monthly payment
that gives you an endless cycle of debt
but
upstart can help you get ahead upstart
is the fast and easy way to pay off your
debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple
fixed month payment unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score like your
income employment history this means
they can offer smarter rates with
trusted partners
with a five-minute online rate check you
can see a rate up front for loans
between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars and you're
going to receive the funds as fast as
one business day after
your loan is accepted so if you want to
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today
go to upstart.com h3
that's upstart.com h3 and don't forget
to use our url
to let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information
provided in your loan application that's
upstart.com
h3
all right we're back and we have a
caller right dan
yeah i've actually uh somebody one of
the mods
from the speedrunning community uh
reached out to me via oh no way
yeah it'd be a discord and said that um
and said that
they wanted to come on and talk about
this whole dream city oh cool
okay so i'd love to hear his thoughts on
it because he would know better than
anyone
minecraft okay you know about minecraft
joe
yeah looky here fatso stop it why is he
always
why do i bring you berate me what did i
do here joe i voted for you
yo buddy i love you man i got myself a
diamond pickaxe dug my way into a world
record
full diamond armor too hand to god hand
to god i'm my boy hunter's surfer you
know and
he's a real he's a real he's got a real
rough go of it
but some dog-haired soldier came in and
burned my village down
okay i sent the service after him burned
his house down in real life
whoa for life man
got his parents audited by the irs too
just a perk of being president
don't grief my minecraft you dingbat
guano breath dirt eater oh what the hell
jesus okay whoa whoa whoa whoa joe pops
up just to be clear joe you're
accusing you literally ruined a
griefer's
life for burning down your minecraft
village that seems like an overreaction
yeah ruin his life running off time for
griefing
yeah so okay but do you think dream
faked his speed run i mean what
what are your thoughts on that look man
you say this guy's a speedrunner
well i used to skip down to the horse
paddy with old bubble ross and shrimp
boys and harvest moon
barn burner and there's this fella soap
shoes a good man he used to tail whip
but tumbleweed faster than him
joe we're talking about um dream you
know the speed
runner that's why you called in right
yeah he could crack a fizzy
lift and drink that would even send
jimmy hines up to grizzlies creek mac
believe me man now that's running with
speed
oh sorry oh oh my oh my
mineconf what oh okay all right
no not my coffman craft my crap okay
all right all right sorry about that joe
that guy does not it's hard to keep him
on topic
it's a little yeah he's getting longer
than the twos bro i don't know what that
is
mineconf why did he say minecraft oh it
kind of sounds like minecraft minecraft
minecraft
i i think he's a little hard of hearing
he's he's he's getting up there in the
age let's not take his calls anymore i
know he's president but
this is like just derailing the show
okay i know it's off the rails but
that's a little too off the road a
little too long copy that
all right and now last week we did um
what did we do last week we did uh
things that piss us off right grinding
our gears
yeah so we're coming at you today with
another round table conversation coming
at you
true unpopular opinions
now i challenge you guys to actually
present me with a truly unpopular
opinion
i think i have an unpopular opinion that
is truly unpopular to the point
that i don't think i've ever met another
person that even agrees with
me hmm really i'm gonna kick it off okay
let's hear it
what you got you guy i i get a lot of
hate for this so please don't get mad
i'm just
i'm just being honest
[Music]
i [ __ ] i think pasta
sucks what pasta as a dish
sucks does anyone agree with me exactly
this is a true unpopular opinion but
trust me this is a well sourced opinion
let me tell you about pasta first of all
every noodle is this [ __ ] same [ __ ]
they got all these fancy noodles with
the swirls
and the knots and the bows and the
the spaghetti it's all it's all the same
it all tastes the same i don't care how
you cut it
first of all okay second of all you want
to talk about calories
pasta is one of the most unhealthy
things you can eat it's not worth the
calories i'd rather eat something else
you give me a pasta a bowl of like
bleached
carbs you know simple cards you might as
well just eat a loaf of bread with
butter i mean what the [ __ ]
that's good too that is good but i want
to eat that for dinner and be like all
good
that's what you're doing when you eat
pasta butter just buttered noodles
people do that but pasta is well aware
it's just as bad it's like
oh i boiled some noodles and i put cream
on it oh i boiled some noodles and i put
butter on it oh i bought something to
put marinara on it it's like
bro give me a break i'm just saying like
you eat a whole bowl of pasta
you're gonna you're clocking a lot of
cows i'd rather have a hamburger a
burrito
you know what i'm saying it's just not
worth it this is anti-italian
discrimination
okay [ __ ] it didn't you have enough yeah
didn't you have an anti-italian opinion
last week too
i was just talking about what did i say
about the italians
what was the thing about the attack oh
it was the video of the people uh
kissing or whatever
oh hey i i was just trying to give the
guy the benefit of the dog hmm
i got nothing against the italians
listen i'm afraid oh
i know it wasn't done i have no one to
blame but myself for this
i know it was you alfredo you ate the
pasta off my dinner table
i wish i could say i was upset but i
didn't want it anyway i know it was you
fredo
i know it was you afraid though that's
what i'm saying this is a true
unpopular opinion yeah no that's a
pretty solid one i don't
wait i'm not done oh jesus homemade
pasta
you know everyone oh you're gonna try
homemade pasta you gotta go oh you gotta
go to a nice italian homemade it's all
let's say it's [ __ ]
i've tried the homemade pasta i've done
all the fancy [ __ ] i've tried it all
it's still
the same [ __ ] it's literally [ __ ]
flour
and like water and sometimes
eggs boiled i get it
what about like a big ziti or something
like that i'm gonna go
so i like okay i'm gonna do a little
carve out for like
i'm not there though like rap i'm just
not there like lasagna that's
interesting because the lasagna it's a
little problem
that's the pasta that's awesome that's
impossible i'll give an honorable
mention to lasagna
because it does so much more it's still
possible you've got a layer
i'm giving i'm just carving out it one
except possible exception
you know you pissed off trisha because
butternoodle is like her favorite dish
yeah well oh wait a minute i know what
this is about
trisha won that cooking competition
oh yeah i'm not done keep on owing over
there i just realized
but at least with us with at least with
um
lasagna it's like there's like the sauce
and the meat and the layers
are all the basil those are all things
that could be on pasta
yeah no customizing it no cheese
but yeah i'll [ __ ] i'll throw a
lasagna out too [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] to me wow
okay i'm not done shame
then you gotta go oh you gotta go to a
nice restaurant get fancy pasta
when you try fancy pasta it's usually
just weird like they put too much wine
in it and it's like tart and weird
it's just you know the harder you try
the worse it is
and then with pasta you go to a
restaurant you order pasta the portions
are insane
it's either way too much or way too
little you get a nice gnocchi dish or a
ravioli you ever order ravioli they give
you like three [ __ ] raviolis
don't lie to me don't you [ __ ] lie to
me you ordered pasta and got three
ravioli yeah no no no and that is
disappointing but often times but i mean
that that the portion
is a determination of the restaurant
it's not the fault and then you ever get
ordered
you ever order like a nice gnocchi dish
so they're like here's five nokias i'm
like i'm sorry
that's the only pasta like possibly
interesting gnocchi and you're gonna
give me five of them how about you eat
[ __ ]
is that technically i don't know if that
it's a pasta
is it this whole conversation just
making me want pasta yeah
i'm not saying hey listen this is my
opinion this is my corner
you could do whatever you want over
there and eat pasta i don't care either
love [ __ ] too hey i don't hate
just saying i think it's [ __ ] you
know
so it's like it's either too much you go
to one of these shitty
italian places they give you oh you want
a noodle of fettuccine
here's a whole lifetime supply of dog
[ __ ] noodles just with
drenched and heavy cream no
it's overrated it's not that good
and most of all my biggest complaint is
that for the calories because it is
very rich unhealthy meal
there are much more fun enjoyable foods
thank you for coming to my ted talk
you see that's a real unpopular opinion
i dare you guys
i dare you guys to try to share
something that vulnerable
uh i think it's because my dad
the only time i ever ate pasta as a
child my dad
he has this dish i swear to god tell me
if you've ever heard of this because i
doubt you have
he calls it burnt onion pasta
it's something his gran his mom ate
apparently he would take onions put in a
grill and then literally
burn them black charred okay like
burnt you know what i'm saying yeah and
then he throw in some noodles with
uh like olive oil and then that was it
and i was i think that traumatized me
maybe i don't know
yeah i mean that's sounds disgusting but
um but i wouldn't hold that again thank
you i guarantee one person watching will
not even agree with me so thank you
that's unpopular next dan your turn
yeah i mean i have a whole list here
like i felt like a b
last week with the things that piss him
off like i struggled on that one but as
far as unpopular opinions
i was able to come up with a bunch but i
don't know if any of these
come anywhere close to just a blanket
[ __ ] pasta stage
that's that's insane thank you i'm out
here uh
what's probably the people
uh i i don't think that everybody should
necessarily you know you can make your
own food choices in life
uh you know i've been a vegetarian for
about a decade now
um and you know that's a personal choice
and i don't try and impose it on
other people however love are you trying
to look at dan from your perspective
because i know that's not where you see
dan it's funny yeah
i was trying to do that uh
people should not eat pigs it's
completely [ __ ] up pigs
are practically sentient creatures
they are there was a study in 2019 that
they
are the only animals more intelligent
than pigs are elephants
chimps and dolphins they're literally
the fourth most intelligent
animal other than human beings they're
far more intelligent than cats and dogs
which we
find abhorrent in this country to eat
and we
harvest them on an industrial scale it's
really [ __ ] up and
i love pigs and you shouldn't eat them
alhamdulillah
you know what dan i don't eat that much
pork i eat like
i don't but but i as someone who does
eat pork
i completely agree i think it's i think
all animals
yeah and again i mean i i i don't eat
any animal but um
you know i'm not gonna try and shove
that down people's syrup but we are
doing an unpopular opinion segment here
okay
oh i think and if there's one animal
that is
commonly served in food everywhere you
go
that uh i really you know really bothers
me the most it's it's pigs you shouldn't
eat pigs people it's
they're they're they're they're they're
they're self-aware
like it's it's [ __ ] up yeah and i've
seen some of those
those pig farms are just absolutely
horrendous it's just it's like an
inhuman yeah it's inhuman it's literally
inhuman yeah
over there i don't know if that's that's
probably not as um popular as uh
but you know that people are so hardcore
about their bacon and their ham and
everything like people that love
so you think eating power eating they
love it you think cow eating is less
severe than pork eating i mean
it's hard to rate these things because i
mean how do we really know what's going
on in the minds of these
creatures i i don't think i don't think
you should eat cows either
but the pig one it just it just always
really gets me on an extra level again
just because of the
the level of their uh yeah i mean like
we we
so you know people have their
interactions and their uh their um
love for their dogs so dan are you
saying if i meet a really dumb human i
can eat him
uh no you probably shouldn't do that
either and again i don't i don't eat
anything
so the dumber they are the more i should
eat of them
it's just when it comes to the level of
suffering that they're enduring
uh you know a level of uh self-awareness
it does seem to um does seem to make
that suffering
uh twinged me a little bit i'm with you
you know what i'm i'm doing the socratic
method here i'm trying to challenge you
on all your beliefs yeah i understand
but i agree with you well then i wasn't
a very good unpopular opinion
i wish i had the strength to become a
vegetarian i wish i did
i really wish i did well you know
well pete if i'm not mistaken pigs eat
their own [ __ ] and cows don't i mean
that's one difference
do they really is that a rumor or do
they really eat their own [ __ ] i just
checked it right now i said they do yeah
so how are they going to claim they're
smart if they eat their own [ __ ] well i
mean
i think they'll pretty much eat anything
but i mean
i i can't i can't i can't talk [ __ ] i'm
the same way you eat your own [ __ ] well
you'd buy pretty much anything
all right dan why i stand with you damn
well i guess i didn't do a very good job
but i'm with you i appreciate the cause
all right fair enough hey b you want to
go
yeah i got i got a really spicy one and
i hope none of the fan base gets uh
upset at me but uh baby's about to be
like i
think woody allen is innocent no no
really crazy take let's hear it thank
you for that but no i was going to say
and i'm being biased i like the h3
podcast better than h3h3
oh no i'll agree with that i mean the
h3h3 videos are class well like
at least at least you get new content
with the podcast
yeah you get new content but also i just
feel like with h3h
like they were great the great videos
great sketches and everything but
the humor i feel like in real life is
always better like you know stuff that
just comes up more naturally
uh i feel like there's just more moments
of that are you just saying that the
[ __ ]
no i swear that's that's my take thank
you abby
and i know we're not talking about stuff
that pisses us off but can i say one
thing
for anyone that's making uh critical
videos of uh
of ethan or h3 um you [ __ ] idiot stop
using the social blade chart of h3h3
he doesn't make videos on that anymore
that is the stupidest proof people do
that
it's it's so bizarre to me yeah they
make a video try to act smart and then
they use
the wrong [ __ ] graph every single
time and it drives me insane wait what
are they oh
maybe i didn't know people were making
hate videos about me and showing yeah
what is the graph
why do you have to bring that up yeah
i'm having a perfectly fine time i'm
sorry
so there's people making hate videos
about me and showing the graph of my old
channel
yeah i mean the graph what like the
subscribers going yeah i'm saying oh
yeah
yeah it's a dead channel i mean yeah i
do and ethan said that many times
himself that
yeah thanks for bringing that up
you hit me with the left you say oh i
love the pocket hit me with the right
everyone's making eight videos about
your dad not everybody you know the same
bottom feeders yeah yeah i ain't
subscribed from that channel long ago
[ __ ] you av you have subscribed from my
channel thank you all right baby
a little love a little hate yeah we like
the balance you gotta balance it out
who's that ian stand up ian stand up
let's go stand up
excuse me let me cut that one excuse me
or i could leave it in it doesn't yeah
it's funny [ __ ] it go ahead and
please stand up stand up
and please stand up please stand up
all right i'm sitting down
uh this just popped in my head i've
i i've had multiple arguments about this
one so i think it's good
i really enjoy
daylight savings time oh my god we've
had this conversation okay this
this is a good one for being popular
daylight savings when they take a
an hour away and it gets dark early
it's hard to explain but i i get kind of
excited
at it because it gets dark early it's
you know the gaining of the hour or the
losing of the hour
either way i get a weird little thrill
about like
god my life's [ __ ] boring hate this
take you're right
you're right this is a great selection
so do you get unhappy when it goes back
to normal
i like going to my oven and like
changing this [ __ ]
you like that huh it feels it feels in a
way this sounds so sad but it feels like
a little mini holiday it's like oh it's
david savings i gotta go
something to do do my microwave
adjustment
so wait how do you feel when it goes
back to
daylight losing or what do you call it
or when you when it
when it hits i don't think it really i
don't think it really matters to him
which direction it's going you just like
clocks change when the clocks change
he's happy it feels like something's
happened
i know what you mean about something
happening we had a vote in california
what was it two years ago it might have
been 2018 where they were
they were putting up to a vote to
abolish daylight savings time here in
the state
um and i remember having this
conversation with ian and he's like i'm
voting no
and i'm like i i lobbied him hard
cause i'm like [ __ ] daylight savings
time it's obnoxious this is antiquated
it's
so dumb and wait did it fail the bill
fail you know no i think it passed i
think it passed what's going on
but the thing was it was the bill was
just
a proposal for the state assembly to
then put together a proposal
it's just some stupid [ __ ] basically
nothing came of it love do you guys do
that in sweden where you change the
clocks
yeah of course and in sweden it's
actually almost needed
yeah it makes more sense in sweden for
sure when you're
in latitude 2 a.m right now or in the
middle of the night
and it's bright outside holy [ __ ] yeah
the sun is coming here
yeah yeah that's a different story
definitely not needed here
ian's voting with the farmers keep
daylight savings
i think that's even a myth that it's for
the farmers who's it for them
it's for me to feel like something
weirdo is like
well ian that certainly was an
interesting one when you
stand up when it moves in it's
technically
later in the day when you wake up
earlier
you feel like you got a little extra
time the sun's up
it's not you're not it's it hits you
know what my interesting take on that is
that i don't even notice
i do nothing i change nothing
i notice nothing it doesn't affect me
you live a lifestyle where you usually
don't have
a deadline to be doing something or be
somewhere early in the morning
hey i vote no i vote keep it no i'm
kidding i'd vote yeah
this isn't like a new opinion like my
luxurious life where i don't
this has always been i've never
acknowledged daylight savings
thank you maybe yes you wanted to
support me please thank you yeah i
support you i said i support ian but i
support you too
i'm surrounded thank you you have that
you have that feeling too like where
it's like it doesn't really affect me
that much
me i'm just yeah i'm i'm just trying to
go to sleep you don't really sleep yeah
so
yeah but like it doesn't [ __ ] matter
who changes their clock in this day and
age i don't i don't change my
electronics
time right most of them automatically do
it but you still you lose an hour of
sleep on the uh
the fall one right can you gain it that
night i mean or not
no it's the spring one spring forward
fall back right okay
all right oh look at that zach i never
heard that before lots of
uh lots of heat here today on the h3
podcast
lots a lot of disagreement the hottest
of the hot takes
who's up next exactly let's go um
i i i that my take could be uh
considered somewhat of a meme
uh but i know a lot of people dislike uh
what i'm about to say
and as the uh in-house rock and roll
trivia history winner i feel like i
should come out and say this that
um people need to stop hating on
nickelback
oh that is pretty unpopular they they
are a good [ __ ] band
you know i know it's a meme like oh [ __ ]
nickelback they have billboard records
all right they write good [ __ ] songs
and there's not a single person sitting
there
that's going to tell me they don't know
a [ __ ] nichols back song and they
they don't
i don't know a nickelback song you need
one for me zach
standing in line the club will never get
in it's like the bottom of the ninth and
i'm never gonna win
i don't know her at all you guys know
rockstar i'm with you zach thank you
rockstar what's another one maybe you
know what you guys should have paid
attention better on the tour because
trisha explained that rockstar was shot
at the playboy mansion by nickelback
it's a solid they are a solid [ __ ]
band look i don't i don't have the
credentials to dispute you on that zack
got you zach
they are solid and they hold billboard
chart records look it up
i believe you no i know they're a top
selling ban that doesn't mean they're
good
they're a fantastic band and people need
to stop hating on them i've always
wondered why they get so much hate
that i don't i don't know what i mean
people throw [ __ ] rocks at them on
stage jesus like
they write good [ __ ] music
it might be considered okay you know the
[ __ ] douche like no
why do people not like them so much i
think people just think they're douchey
and yeah i've heard things about the
lead singer being a dude chad kroger
and his name is chad kroger bro how do
you forgive that
he he just just the records they make
really good songs i'm just i just want
to say that i just wanted
to hear one i'm i'm a closeted
nickelback fan
not anymore yeah yeah you're out in the
open now yeah
nickelback i mean that's a great take
zach i gotta say that's a that's a good
that's a genuine thank you
unpopular opinion and honestly i i have
nothing to say really in in response
uh well here why doesn't why here why
does nickelback
get a bad reputation this is google's
answer right now it's become trendy to
hate nickelback and no one even knows
why
the band's tour manager said the main
argument people make for hating
knuckleback
is that their music is bland and generic
and all their songs sound the same
yeah true i don't see i don't but that's
the vibe you're getting with them i'm
not saying they're the greatest band in
the world
i'm just saying they they write quality
music here's another summary
zach what's so bad about nickelback
nickelback is too much of everything to
be enough of something
okay i try to bend my mind trying to
explain so hard
i'm kind of team zack after reading that
thank you they follow
genre expectations too well which is
seen as
empty imitation but also not well enough
which is read as commercial tactics and
a lack of stable sincere identity
i think i think where it hit bad for
them was they they were signed
i think they still might be to a label
called road runner and they wanted to
make them
like the next it band which they did but
in doing so they made them come off like
douches
oh here's a here's a good one nickelback
became the world's most hated band
because they churned out formulaic
generic music
behaved child childishly in public and
wrote misogynistic content
into their lyrics wow wow
zach do you hate women no are you sure
because
you're defending them that the
misogynist i i did not know about that's
cancelled
i did not i did not know wow zach i'm
actually i'm trying to find examples of
their
massage could you say that with any rob
song like
yeah like steven tyler uh yeah had sex
with like
14 years [ __ ] the 12 year old beyond the
hood of my car
that's like every lyric i mean any any
rock song i mean you you could
say it does no i'm with you yeah yeah i
mean i i don't know
nickelback's music well enough to you
know cite specific examples i
i can tell you you know there were a
rock radio staple for years right in
like the late 90s and 2000s and
uh every time i ever heard something
from them it
bored me to death so well there you go
it's just like you want to sit back and
have a good beer you put on some [ __ ]
nickelback
bro i i as much as i as much as i
support you i feel like if you're
hanging out with people and put on
nickelback
you'll they'll not hang out with oh yeah
no no no that's that's why
you know you got to keep it on the
secret but you got to keep it on the
deal right
so i'm i'm just making my stance right
now that oh they're the look at this
photograph
right right oh yeah okay
oh that song is so annoying dude there's
a really funny um
no i there's a really funny thing about
the talking meme of them
wrong yeah right where they go look at
this [ __ ] guy
they edit it to make it sound like and
then they play something
i know they'll look at this graph one
look at this [ __ ] guy
i mean just look at him though zach i
mean the guy the bro
he looks like me he looks like
[ __ ] i'm not saying like by any means is
he a musical
influence but well okay zach has a beard
not a goatee and mustache
that's pretty douchey but it's
everything going on in his face is wrong
right but i'm just saying he's got a gel
necklace
he's got a decent voice and they're
right good [ __ ] songs whether what he
looks like
you know he it makes good [ __ ] vlogs
i see why people hate this guy
well yeah it just screams dude kroger
bruh it just screams douchebag
and i'm not denying that i'm just saying
people need to start
you know if you're a nickelback fan it's
okay that's what i'm saying okay
okay i like that statement that's a good
statement i think that's a really good
one
thank you good job zach thank you look
at this [ __ ] guy
so keemstar you know i love talking
about keemstar he's
he's the worst person i know worse than
his saddam hussein
literally you know i feel like keemstar
would do more damage
in iraq than saddam hussein let's be
honest i'm anti-semitic
you know he's basically waging wars
against humanity on youtube
i'm busted yeah so anyway he got in a
twitter fight with like a bunch of
twitch streamers and got ratioed by them
all
people were just clowning on him which i
love but hassan actually made a
groundbreaking revelation about keemstar
he said
you are legally not allowed to be near
schools
keemstar is not allowed near schools
that's so interesting i didn't know that
about him
i wonder why usually they don't let
people in your schools if they're like
sexual offenders right
uh yeah well i don't know i didn't know
i didn't know that about him either is
that verified well
hassan said you are legally not allowed
near schools
right assuming that i'm just insinuating
that
that keemstar may be a sexual predator
right
so frustrated if he's not allowed in
your schools i don't know
yeah i i i feel like we should
definitely take what hassan is saying
on face value without any kind of
follow-up and just assume that yeah he's
right
he's gotta have insider information i
heard that he has to knock on all of his
neighbor's doors every time he moves
that's why he doesn't move because he's
had this house in buffalo he lives at
for so long oh joy doesn't move because
he has to alert all his neighbors
yeah that would be a hassle it's like a
romeo julia
no i'm kidding i don't know that
information this is a joke this is
parody
parody he may be a predator but i have
no information too
you have no way of saying one way or the
other hassan does though he says you are
legally not
allowed near that sounds official yeah
that's a that's an official statement
yeah we actually uh somebody reached out
to me on discord
uh they want to call in and apparently
they were a neighbor of
keemstars what yeah dude and they that's
what they say
um but supposedly you know
i guess if they were a neighbor they
would have some info about you know him
whoa this is groundbreaking
yeah so um let me uh let me queue it up
let me get them in here
gotcha man got your [ __ ] oh what's up
biden got your man yo how is he doing
this what has he got like nsa resources
how do you keep getting at our discord
bro don't you have a country to run
you got a guy got hackers every area
code
all right what do you want to talk if
you want to talk about keemstar
now you listen here jack i'll show you a
beanstalk i've heard it is keemstar
fella
okay i'm going to talk about keemstar
mule on a
bugle beater speedway i'll tell you why
i just passed an executive order bannon
keemstar from being a hundred feet
within schools man
trust me oh nice
yeah man look how he's smelling a little
girl's hair as much as the next guy
best buy but this keemstar ain't right
in the head man
my granddaddy told me never trust a man
with a beard that black man it ain't
right i'm right
there it's true oh that's good advice
that is good advice from your dad
you're not you're trying to make a
little sense here yeah it's getting more
coherent as this goes okay
look man my son he died of brain cancer
and i thought that was a bad experience
but i just
watched a drama alert and let me tell
you that was worse
man if you were a willy waddling down
old man winter's bag of bones oh that is
okay
fine dj keeps our melon munching and
salomon hollows down by the abandoned
beer
all right myself whoa
all right i mean i i'm happy to hear
that somebody's finally doing something
about the keemstar problem
hmm do you wanna okay well um
did you i guess did you see that
everyone was roasting him on twitter i
guess you were enjoying
you follow keem of all keemstar drama i
mean you're the president what the [ __ ]
are you doing
i don't remember playing the guitar what
i i know a fellow once a real son of a
birch tree as a matter of fact
the guitar he played was made of birch
beautiful grains in the woods
okay all right all right enough joe
biden let's be honest we've got andrew
callahan of all gas snow breaks he's got
a
absolutely incredible story to tell he
used to run
all gas no brakes the beloved channel
that we've we've had him on the show
super popular amazing kind of
journalistic comedy show
and he had like a really dramatic
breakup
with his partners i guess you would say
on
um all guys snow breaks and he started a
new channel channel five on youtube you
can subscribe
follow on patreon channel five anyway
i've got andrew on
the line and i'm we're going to talk to
him about all this and all of his new
content it's going to be great
okay we have with us today the one and
only andrew callahan
for the artist formerly known as all gas
no breaks
now known as channel 5.
hey how are you what's up man good to
see you it's been a long time
it has been a long time i love you i
love your content
and i'm just very because you you were
guessing our podcast and
a popular guest too people love people
just love you
and your content and hearing you talk
and i'm absolutely fascinated riveted
by the switch up to channel 5
from all gas no breaks this is very
interesting
a little business drama could you say i
mean a little business drama i just you
know i didn't just like i didn't expect
the channel to be that big i didn't
expect [ __ ] to get that ugly once uh you
know
it came down to it but it was a it was a
weird transition but like
if it was really hard to give up
something that was like it's like your
child you know like you spend so much
time
putting effort into something and you
feel so much like pride about it but
at the end of the day i had to sacrifice
all gas snow breaks
to be independent so i'm happy that i
did that so tell me what happened
so basically like um so around six
months ago
say like november december i started
shooting a movie with tim and eric
and a couple other partners who like
we've yet to announce
but basically like i was shooting
full-time for like the
absolutely tim and eric movie and uh
basically the company that i used to
work for doing things media who
owned all gas mill brakes so i signed
the contract with when i was super young
they were kind of being like yo like
it's cool you're doing the movie we need
you to make
you know make more content like you know
basically work double duty to make the
movie and
the the instagram and youtube show all
gas no breaks
and uh i couldn't do it like i literally
couldn't do it like i was work shooting
like almost seven days a week
for the absolute movie and and all that
and so i told him like yo
i will do it but i need like a little
bit more of a percentage because
when i signed the deal around that time
i was only making 20
of money from the show that's what they
were getting like just just to clarify
for the people listening because we've
talked about this privately
20 of the ad revenue 20 of the merch
and twenty percent of the patreon which
has had grown quite
large yeah i was making like almost a
hundred thousand dollars plus a month
but i was only seeing twenty percent of
that
but you know i'm not going to blame the
company i signed the deal when i was
super young
all gas snow breaks started with me
hitchhiking across the country writing
stories about it like i told you
they bought me the rv i was like [ __ ] it
i don't even care about the money i just
love to like be
on the road like diving into weird [ __ ]
all the time like i wasn't thinking
about like oh i need to make as much
money as i could because i was like 21
years old
so i didn't i didn't expect things to
evolve so much and
go down so quickly but here's what
happened so i'm shooting for the movie
under a lot of pressure to make more
videos uh i basically said okay
you know i'll make more videos if you
give me more of a percentage
i'm saying this because this all came
out in the new york times you know uh i
was like you know if you want me to make
more
videos for you while i'm shooting the
movie need a little bit more like money
you know because it's like i don't want
to work two jobs i'm not getting paid
for two jobs worth
look you're bringing you're growing the
channel you're grinding at a certain
point you gotta
visit that contract right but especially
like i couldn't even make
all gas no brakes videos if i wanted to
because i was shooting constantly for
this movie which
hopefully will be announced soon and by
the way were they were they involved in
this movie at all because you were
were you doing that as andrew cavanaugh
yeah they're they're partners but
what the [ __ ] they want they're already
getting a piece of that what do they
want from you
well i mean obviously the digital show
is more profitable than
the movie like you can make more money
off of youtube and patreon
than you can with a movie especially
like a movie might come out in eight
months from when you start
yeah i mean like a movie might come out
for them it's like they wanted like
money like right then and there you know
they're making 80 percent of
money from the show that i was making
like basically by myself
so um they said no to my offer you know
so things kind of got kind of stopped
talking to them things kind of went sour
and then you know they fired nick and
evan via email
those are yours who you started out with
who go in the rv with you yeah yeah
yeah they fired them and this is
whenever we were like sleeping in the rv
uh in the cold in philadelphia at the
walmart they got termination notices in
their email
i was like [ __ ] sorry guys like you're
out of a job man i don't know what to
tell you
that was really hard for me to do but
then they ultimately just like
at that point i was like i wanted to get
out of the contract you know i was like
this is crazy like my two best friends
are fired
i can't do this so i just started not
making any videos i was like i'm gonna
make this movie all the time and then
they sent me a
some in the mail that said that if i
didn't produce a certain amount of
pieces of patreon content by like
i think it was march 1st not quite sure
i'd be terminated
and then yeah they just they fired me in
the middle of shooting for the movie man
that's
they're such they seem like such a like
short not only like douchey but like so
short-sighted i mean yeah y'all could
have made it
really confusing yeah like i mean i've
if they would have said
yes to my offer i probably would still
be doing all gas no breaks
you know because i wanted to make it
work i didn't want to say goodbye to my
show forever
you know and just have it be this thing
that i worked so hard on that i have no
control over
but at the end of the day like i'm
having more fun with the channel 5 the
patreons pop in like
youtube numbers are pretty good you know
like it feels good to own my own masters
now and not have to like
answer to anybody so at the end of the
day like it was a small
setback for what i think will be like a
better return yeah part of the reason
i wanted to talk to you today is because
i want people to know andrew
is on channel five and if you are
supporting him on patreon on august no
breaks
all that's going to these these uh
[ __ ] goons who stole the show from
you i don't give a [ __ ] i'll say it you
don't have to say it i'll say it
they stole the show bro so don't don't
support them on patreon channel five on
patreon all day
and on youtube i appreciate it bro yeah
i want to start getting into like new
platforms like i want to start doing
like
twitch [ __ ] like tick tock stuff like
you know i know you guys do all that but
i want to like learn how to use i don't
know how to use new platforms and like
just like trying to [ __ ] out like like
live streaming because i live out of my
truck now
i'm still on the road we're about to buy
like an old-school news van like an nbc
1995 van
yeah decal it out with channel five [ __ ]
and like put satellite dishes and all
that we're just gonna travel around the
country and like find like dumb mass
small town drama and make like
investigative documentaries on it
so like at that point like that's gonna
be tight so let me ask you
have they i know they're like trying to
find a replacement for you which
it's just the arrogance of these people
have they
been able to produce any content at all
since you left
no but um it just so happens and it's
not something i'm seeking out but
they've tried a couple times to find a
new host and uh
on a couple occasions the i didn't
publish any information
obviously because i don't have like a
huge grudge against this company it's
whatever i'm moving on
i do but for you people who people who
have tried to replace me they've tried
to find replacements their replacements
have reached out to me
and it didn't work out oh well one
replacement in particular
almost crazy there's so much components
to the all gas no breaks genius
it's you as the host and it's also the
editing it's the vibe
it's the whole [ __ ] thing like you
can't bottle that and
reproduce it it's just it's mental
yeah i mean i totally agree and that's
like the case i tried to make when i was
trying to negotiate
for myself but they just told me like
it's okay we have connections in the
comedy world like
we'll find a replacement man that's all
and then people are loyal to you too
it's just such a train it's like i can't
imagine making a worse business decision
even and also just being so vindictive
it's like
um they it's like they
they killed the goose that laid the
golden egg bro
yeah that's how i felt too man i was
like [ __ ] i put everything into this and
i kept like gaslighting myself kind of
being like am i crazy for asking for
this like do i deserve any money
like i don't know man when you're back
against the wall and there's people
in your ear telling you that like you're
only a small part of the whole
thing [ __ ] you are that listen to
yourself
yeah i was shocked when i heard that i
was like wow man i was like i'll buy
yours yeah dude straight up
i was like i want a piece of the
accident
no for straight i'm glad we can talk
about it because like like i said like
it's not even
i have no like grudge against the
company you know i mean that's how
companies do
you know it happens time and time again
if people have an opinion but i mean
i feel like independence is the only way
and it's like the noble way too
you know what i mean so you probably i
have a suspicion you're probably even
making more money now already
um close close to making enough money
but honestly dude like
i only want money so i can like do
crazier and cooler [ __ ] like i just went
to a q a on convention in dallas last
weekend and i'm going to vegas tomorrow
to get pick up pick up artist training
so it's like oh baby yeah it's gonna be
tight and like so the money is just like
sick ass old cameras and like gas money
and flights for everybody
so i'm really curious about is there is
there patreon like
bleeding i haven't they they i don't
even know
if you have intelligence yeah let me
know
because the patriot dog no breaks
patreon had like 20
000 there's like really good lots of
supporters there
doesn't look like their patreon numbers
are public but um oh they hid them
because before they were published for
sure
yeah they're like oh [ __ ] this isn't
working
yeah one thing about the companies they
weren't like huge dicks they weren't
mean to me or anything while we worked
together they had a pretty good working
relationship until
you know the contract [ __ ] came up like
i don't have like strong negative
feelings
but man like that whole capital c like
digital content factory
you know man it's crazy it's like you
were saying that people who
who were attempted to uh replace you
did they have any interesting anecdotes
yeah you know it's like i don't know how
much i can say
but one dude in particular i felt so
[ __ ] bad for him and like
he was i think he was told when he was
going to replace me that like
some of my friends were still involved
and that i was going to vouch for him
and
give like a smooth transition of power
to him and all that stuff
and uh after he figured out what was
going on
just like bye oh they're lying to people
now to replace you
uh bro well anyway enough about that
your new content
on channel five is amazing it's the same
[ __ ] i mean it's
it's you it's just as good as it ever
was
i was watching this one about the um the
white live matters protest
yeah you know
i'm so interested about like first of
all this guy is amazing
the kobe boy here let me kobe bryant was
killed by the clintons right how many
people know that they assassinated kobe
bryant they tried to kill tiger woods in
that car accident recently why
the kobe bryant deal is he had dirt on
the uh on the clintons
i love black people i love everybody
we're all god's children isn't this a
white lives matter rally
uh well i'll tell you what this whole
thing with the virus would be
you believe he didn't know he was at a
white lives matter
well okay here's the thing i talked to
l.a weekly journalists about that
specific event
uh if you look at the way that event was
designed and promoted via social media
it was like this super like sleek
looking
graphically pleasing like white lives
matter rally it was definitely planned
by like a it was like a psyop to try to
identify white nationalists after the
january sixth capital right oh you think
it was for sure interesting
oh [ __ ] yeah because it absolutely was
because there was no central leadership
there was no one there being like hey
i'm the organizer it was weird kind of
like
fringe dudes like that guy who kind of
fell victim to the uh facebook
marketing yeah facebook marketing and
stuff like and i even went to the page
you try to contact them and like no
there's like no reply send error really
weird they're just trying to
i don't know who's like i'm not even
going to be right there straight up
too that's [ __ ] crazy it's probably
the fbi you think it's the fbi but
that's kind of epic
yeah yeah you're the enemy yeah
you're doing real ism out there i swear
to god thanks man what better way to
identify
violent white nationalists and like
violent left-wing people there to
confront them
than to schedule a fake clan rally in
california well you know there was one
guy here that i it's funny to say that
there was one specific guy who was like
i was there i think you know where i was
on january 6th where were you same guy
i think you know where i was on january
6th trump is still in the fbi's like oh
did you get those shoes done
those are just but yeah i was kind of
interested because it felt like
i did i got the impression that the
people that were there
were just like misguided trump
supporters not necessarily like super
crazy racist violent people although
that guy was at january six
but then the counter protesters were
getting like super
super charged up the ante i guess antifa
i don't know what you call them
is that proper i mean just left-wing
militant left-wing protesters whatever
you want to call them people throw hands
at a counter protest
yeah dude i mean a lot of those people
men like at the white lives matter rally
like that that
kobe bryant was assassinated by the
clintons guy like he's definitely a
misinformation victim i mean he was
i had a conversation with him off camera
and i was asking him like so where do
you get your news from like
how do you consume information and he
was telling me about these like [ __ ]
up weird fringe podcasts that he listens
to he's like i listened to uh
this one podcast called patriot street
fighter for like 12 hours a day which
encourages him to like go out and like
get into brawls with the
antifa or whatever i honestly feel bad
for that guy he seems like a nice guy
and then you start to learn about his
life story like
his what his wife left him it took the
kids and [ __ ]
it's just like all tragedy i feel bad
for anyone who feels compelled to engage
in like uh
political and counter political violence
in any capacity against
other humans like [ __ ] people like
the people getting rich off of this
conflict or just sitting back smiling
and laughing hard as [ __ ] you know
zuckerbergs and everything just like you
know propagating division it's like
everyone's making money the news
stations even me i'm making money by
making this video
it's literally just like and people are
going to jail it's just classic
choreography
that uh it's been happening you ever
feel bad you're like damn i'm here
making money and these people are all
just like such victims or
do you ever well i mean i would but i'm
tr i'm like actually trying to show
what's going on
yeah you know and like most of the money
i make goes into making like more stuff
like you know
i went to just show how ridiculous the
situation was
i'm like you got people here thinking
that it's a white lives matter rally who
were
just coaxed into the snafu by facebook
misinfo and then you got [ __ ]
on the left like that kid with the
skateboard
who like wants to kill this guy yeah
he's like i literally want to kill you
i hope you that die really intense
because i got the feeling watching that
video that i was like i bet these dudes
if they met in a bar or
somewhere like neutral they could work
this [ __ ] out
oh yeah the mutual humanity goes super
ignored
and it's sad well i do
as funny and entertaining as your videos
are i've always got the sense that it
like
in a lot of ways it educates me at
what's really going on on the ground
more than yeah [ __ ] reading uh
article about it could you know
so we um
[Applause]
um oh there's one other guy i want to
talk about before i let you go
uh spring break this is another channel
five classic
by the way you're at 500 000 subs wasn't
all gas no brakes at 1 million so you're
like halfway there right
i think augusta breaks like 1.7 million
and this is actually the first interview
i've done to promote channel 5 i mean
like
in a way i just like let it do its thing
oh
dude and i want you all to go to all gas
no breaks and leave a comment that says
what's the name of the company
i don't even want to start [ __ ] like
that
[Laughter]
i was just gonna say okay let's leave it
at that you guys know what to do foot
soldiers melt up
what's going on bro what's up what's on
your mind what do you think about all
the ass out here
do you eat it what i eat ass you eat it
ass look at that ass
don't just want to eat it yeah i yellow
come eat ass with me tonight
[Music]
you're not afraid to eat ass are you
[Music]
okay so we're eating ass tonight kirby's
at eight me may 8 30.
[Music]
that [ __ ] guy disturbed what does it
mean to eat ass together andrew
like one tongue two tongues one butthole
or what what happened at 8 30.
yeah did you meet him at 8 30. i did not
meet him at 8 30. i went to fort
lauderdale because you know how they
were militarizing miami beach to stop
people from uh from turning up
but everyone just went to broward county
which is like 15 20 minutes north
and just kept it going so i followed the
party but i do wonder if that guy waited
for me
uh outside that bar i would have loved
to know if he was there at 8 30 waiting
for you
dude miami beach is like hell on earth
like ocean drive like i never want to go
back there again that's it i have to go
to rolling loud next month
i want to like interview rap fans like
trying to stop things i got that same
impression when i
i went to miami beach once with uh ila
when we're going to meet dj khaled
and i felt the same i was like this is
hell on [ __ ] earth this place is a
nightmare man
dj khaled lives at my other beach
um yeah he's in fl yeah he's in yeah i
think so
is he down by kiba skater he lives like
in an ocean drive apartment he's in like
a beautiful ocean drive like
okay so you just imagine they came in
like a [ __ ] one bedroom
they got us a hotel down there we want
some competition
it's this is like old memes but our fans
rigged a
valentine's day competition where the
prize was go meet dj khaled in miami
and we so they flew us down and put us
up in miami and we [ __ ]
spent a day with dj khaled it was wild
that's kind of sick was he tired we see
that kind of weird
super nice bro and i gave him a lot of
[ __ ] too like i'm embarrassed looking
back at the things i put him through
but he was what do you what did you make
him do
because we made like a whole shitload of
videos goofing on him back in the day
that was like kind of our whole
we made like five videos just [ __ ]
on dj khaled
and uh i made him watch him
damn but i mean it was real torture it
was it was good man but he had a good
sense of humor about him
i was impressed by him bro i can't say a
bad thing about khalid he was
he was a good dude good yeah
what's a celebrity you really didn't
like hmm
interesting i know one bit
i can't say you can't just say it bro
i was just thinking jake paul we had him
on the phone he's not a celebrity he's a
[ __ ] he's a celebrity
jake paul's obviously with him how do
you
how do you handle so much youtube beef
all the time
lots of antidepressants
i'm like jesus dude i'd be so high
anxiety if i was you you're getting
sued you're [ __ ] my my exposing
people
yeah my energy my anxiety levels are
just always at a humming at a perfect uh
95 percent so i just got used to sailing
at that right
how's theodore theater's great he's
turning two on the fourth two days from
now
ela's pregnancy any funny stuff was you
have us having a second kid we're having
a second kid it's family time
damn what are you going to name it we
don't know what it is yet
um twins too we have a feeling that it
might even be twins so we're in for
oh man we're in for it now boy
speaking of twins you guys should go
watch uh the latest
channel 5 video it was you know my
cameraman nick have you met him before
i don't know did i meet him at your
house when we did the podcast together
yeah i think you might have met him
pretty briefly he just did his first
solo documentary oh the hoff twins
that was twins yeah yeah oh how fun
that's one of my faves of all time i i
did i haven't watched it yet but i saw
people buzzing around about it
cool [ __ ] yeah um
go guys channel five support andrew
callahan he's a real one
doing real [ __ ] so patreon youtube
everywhere get on it
instagram you can ask me anything you
can ask me anything anything
bro do it [ __ ] it do you still oh yeah
okay when's the last time you got laid
um yesterday oh good who's the girl is
it
random or a girlfriend uh somewhere in
between
okay yeah you're going steady you're not
seeing other girls though
are you are you well i mean yeah it's
like
i like to move around so much that it's
kind of hard to maintain
like a consistent relationship but yeah
definitely i mean we'll see what about
you man
oh yeah i'm married uh last time i had
sex with let's see ela's been pregnant
for
she's been pregnant about five weeks so
about five weeks
i'm gonna come um
you still wanna um the bachelor we were
talking about that
do you think i have enough like swag
yeah definitely
really you still dumped out i'm [ __ ]
down what when do
how do i do it all right we'll set it up
we'll contact you
we got to start dude well the thing is
we got to start the application process
we got to get girls to apply
and then we start this sounds fun yeah
if you're really down i'll do it and
i'll start like working out hella and
then get the spray tans and anything
like that just make myself
sick i'm just going to warn you this is
not a joke we've done it two
previous seasons and they've both ended
up
in true romance really
have any of them fallen through ian met
sam
she's moved to la they live together now
what they've been together two years ian
two years and then trisha was our second
one she's engaged now to moses they're
getting married at the end of the year
so i'm just telling you guys this is a
real [ __ ]
i'm all in 100 100 success rate and so
yeah i'm just
okay great went to this movie movie
announcement bro
i'm waiting on it it's going to be i'm
so excited when you see the announcement
when you see it
like like it's crazy
do you are you guys pitching are you
like have you gotten the press over
there okay you're gonna wait it's damn
near done
so you're gonna finish it and then try
to sell it to whomever
nah it's been it's it's already oh it's
locked in
locked someone already bought it or
you can't say is it streaming or network
we'll figure it out i can't even i can't
talk about it baby but i'm gonna watch
that yeah
yeah yeah for sure i'm hoping it gets
announced in the summertime it's like oh
man when you see this trailer why
i'm super pumped and you know i love
absolutely who
who's basically they plucked you to make
this right like
like eric richard oh yeah we need to
talk with i'm sitting i'm at the ufo
mega conference in this shitty town
called laughlin nevada in south nevada
and i'm at this
casino and i get a dm from eric wareham
he's like yo
what's you want to make a show we
pitched the show
every network rejected it really and
then uh
yeah it's really funny for whatever
reason what was the show can you
talk about what it was oh it was just it
was just like an august snow breaks like
that
show and like didn't work out but i'm
happy and then we got a little movie
thing going on and
that's all i can really say wow that's
like a dream come true i gotta say like
as a young budding comedian or artist of
any kind to get plucked out by
the likes of tim and eric who are like
the kind of godfathers of modern comedy
i love those two guys
yeah shout out to uh dave kneebone too i
met the of newborn
i pitched a show today never called me
back uh
[ __ ] don't bring me into this man no but
i love him i love him the show was
half-baked i don't blame him it wasn't
good
the only i got in there because i was
pitch i was uh working with justin
roiland
who's like who knows those guys he's
like hey my friend wants to pitch a show
so he got us the meeting and um it was
like half baked so
i i don't blame him do you think i
should start
do you think i should start streaming uh
would that be kind of corny or like can
i do it in a cool way like i'm trying i
don't really know how it works i just
know that it's super like
try it i mean you have nothing to lose
by trying it and seeing if it if it
if it's i kind of just want to like walk
around random small towns that i'm in
and just like talk to people and like
stream it but that's kind of like weird
i don't know i have to figure out a way
to do it dude streaming's weird like i
feel like anything
can work these days it really just and
streaming is kind of its own different
art art so you got to just
get in there and feel it out and see
other people like it yeah
i just want to try new stuff man like
yeah give it a shot i mean twitch is
good youtube is a great place to stream
too
you got all your fans here on youtube so
if you start a live stream there's gonna
be a lot of people tuning in
it's a pretty good idea i just wanna
like you know make channel five like a
whole universe of different shows and
different platforms
great idea yeah and you know youtube has
like a tick tock style like they call it
shorts i think
so you can make six dogs you can make
the shorts for youtube put them on on
tiktok get everything popping
how's your take talk career going i
remember your first one crushing it bro
let me check
i'm at 1.5 million let's [ __ ] go bro
damn
[ __ ] about some stats tick tock is so
fun because you just dude there's no
pressure to make anything good
you just should post some people yeah i
mean one of the reasons that one
the one i want to do that's all of our
political content on youtube gets
demonetized as well
oh i gotta okay so i've been watching
your videos i gotta give you
tips bro because i see this [ __ ] and i'm
like oh
i'm like this video would do so much
better let me tell you in the first 30
seconds
this is crucial you cannot curse at all
i see you dropping f-bombs in the first
30 seconds
and that it make immediately makes it
get demonetized and mature rated too
so it's not going to be recommended so
the fact that you're even getting like
half a million views on some of these is
is pretty amazing because
i feel like if you were just a little
bit more knowledgeable about youtube
norms then you would be getting even
more views
what if i yeah what if i bleeped out
like certain stuff in the first minute
so i think as long as there's no cursing
the first 30 seconds you're good
and then other things like racial slurs
or like threats of violence and [ __ ]
like that you could bleep i think that
would help too
but i'll tell you what i'll do there's a
there's a system
there is a system in place for
big channels where you can send it to
get pre-approval from youtube
and and then they'll be like yo so this
part
here is going to get you dinged so if
you want to change it you can and then
we'll we'll give it a green light
and then it will never get demonetized
so you get this really great feedback
i can hook you up i mean i'll try i'll
hook you up with the people that run
that program and see if they'll let you
in
thank you homie i appreciate it that
would be huge for us bro yeah i want to
help you out however i can you're the
man bro
well thanks for having me on this [ __ ]
was awesome all right guys channel 5 it
is what it is
looking forward to the movie
announcement dude we'll talk then for
sure oh man i can't wait sounds good
let's
go movie theater at home movie theater
at home oh
[ __ ] i don't know if you stick me in the
theaters though
if it was in the theaters i would just
go to random screenings in small towns
and like sit in the back
then when it's done just dab everyone
out up on the way out you know you never
know you say
you say that this movie is not going to
make as much as youtube you don't know
dude sometimes these movies just [ __ ]
go crazy with like a million dollar
budget they turn a crazy profit
yeah for sure i'm sure i'm sure it's
going to pop bro
for sure all right thanks for calling
dog keep it up thank you breakfast
channel 5 all day every day thanks man
all right until next time
all right that's it we got a show here
folks
that's off the rails
should i wrap it up here i guess so yeah
because this is the end
that's off the rails guys thanks for
watching you know what it is
totally off the rails destroying our
office
until we just sit among a pile
of rubble
that's right whoa
i was really off the rails today anyway
guys
come join us on friday after dark
everybody's favorite
day of the week is friday baby with ela
cline my beautiful wife
and co-host get back on the rails no
i will not get back on the rails unless
it's friday
and we got a great show on friday so
please join us then until then thank you
for watching
stay good stay safe and stay blessed
[Music]
[Music]
you